Bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
To define what kind of
lethal damage they will do,
I'm going to take your weapons
and deliver some lethal blows
to this ballistics dummy.
Jacob, you're up first, ready?
-Cut the head off.
-Let's do that.
All right.
Jacob, let's talk about
your sickle sword right here.
Your edge is razor-sharp coupled
with the fact
that this is
a very light weapon.
I can use velocity
to really wield that sharp edge.
It cuts deep into
this ballistics dummy,
and overall, sir,
your weapon will kill.
-Thank you.
-All right.
Robert, your turn, sir,
you ready?
-I'm ready.
-Let's do this.
All right. Robert, let's talk
about your sickle sword.
It's a very light blade,
that much lighter
than the other one,
and the angle that you have
in here lends itself to use
not only velocity
but the sharpness of your edge
to cut very deep
into this ballistics dummy,
and overall, sir,
you'll kill.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test,
the armored warrior chop.
To test the strength
and overall durability of
your Mesopotamian sickle swords,
I'm going to be chopping
into these armored warriors.
Jacob, you're up first.
You ready for this?
-I don't think I get a choice.
-You don't have a choice.
Come on.
What actually happened is,
your sword bit into
the other sword
by about 3/16ths of an inch,
and it took out this chip,
and once that chip was gone,
the whole sword blew up.
Your grain looks good,
but unfortunately it's just
this sword against that sword.
That time, that sword won.
-Yep.
-All right. Jacob,
we hate to see this happen.
You gave us a beautiful blade,
but unfortunately it did
suffer catastrophic failure
on the seventh strike,
but you are not out
of the fight yet
because, Robert, in order
to become the champion,
you will have to survive
every single one of those
seven strikes
on the armored warrior.
Are you ready?
-Let's roll the dice.
-All right, Ben.
Good job.
Well, Robert, the big thing is,
it's one sword, nice job.
Thank you.
Well, Robert, you made it
through all the testing.
Jacob, it's a beautiful
piece of work.
Unfortunately due to
your catastrophic failure,
we cannot continue testing it.
For that reason,
I'm going to have to ask you to
please step off the forge floor.
Thank you, gentlemen.
It was an honor.
-Thank you very much.
-Very nice job.
Thank you.
It totally sucks,
but I really am proud
of the blade I made either way.
They said pretty much nothing
but good things about it up
until it broke, and, well,
I'd totally come back for this
and maybe get a shot at
making it all the way through.
Robert, we never like to see
competitors' blades break,
but yours did not,
and that makes you the newest
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You just got yourself a check
for $10,000, congratulations.
-Thanks, thanks.
-Feel pretty good?
Crazy, dude, crazy.
Winning this championship
I think has really pushed me
to my limits,
and then that makes me
want to push them even more.
Now I'm a champion.
I'm going to go ahead
and get my ABS smith membership
and just really refine
my skills.